what was the translation applied to move  the blue solid shape to the orange  dashed shape so if you start with the  blue this blue shape the blue solid  shape and you want it to be shifted to  where this orange dotted shape is how  would you do that and the way I like to  think about is just pick a point and see  what happened to that had what had to  happen to that point so this point at  the top of this I guess this  quadrilateral looking thing it moved  down here so it moved one to the left  and it moved one down so we can denote  that with the transformation moving one  to the left is negative one in the  horizontal direction if we move to the  right it would have been positive one  and we moved one down in the vertical  direction and that is another negative  one